uh this is really good so this is a
black activist I would say an activist
who happens to be Black by the name of
Bob Woodson on the Dr Phil show talking
about what has happened in the black
community and how it relates to
basically everything we're talking about
here today you say you don't support
reparations why not not everybody
suffered equally I mean when you go into
slavery
it's more much more complex than or
white people were the oppressors and
black people were the victims
if you if you dissect it you'll find
there are about
3700 free bikes who own 12 000 slaves
black slaves the question is
do the descendants of those free blacks
who own black slave do they pay blacks
really uh benefited more the first
hundred years after slavery we have in
the last 50 years I was born in 1937
doing the depression
everyone in my small low-income black
community
98 of the households had a man and a
woman raising children
elderly people could walk safely in that
Community without fear of being
assaulted by their grandchildren never
heard a gunfire during that time never
heard of a child being shot to death in
the crib but there are 50 children today
who have been shot and killed in our
cities if you talk you talk about
remedies we've got to look Beyond of
saying that that every solution has to
have a a winner and a loser that blacks
can only benefit if whites lose we have
to be defined more than just victims of
Oppression when whites were at their
worse blacks are at their best when we
were denied access to uh to to hotels we
built our own we have to communicate to
our people
this the the history of how they
achieved in the face of Oppression but
if we continue to sit back and say all
of the challenges that we face in a out
of wedlock birth of violence that
somehow why do the control of that is is
in the hands of White America and
therefore until white people change
there's nothing that we can do
this sets up a terrible situation for
this nation the big crisis facing
America is not racial it is a moral and
spiritual freefall that is consuming our
children
the highest uh uh death rate among black
families is homicide
among uh Silicon Valley
the highest level of suicide six times
the national average
in Appalachia
the prescription drugs and so if we are
to address this crisis that is causing
our children to to lack a sense of of
personal responsibility or value for
their own life they will take their own
life or take someone else's
so in order to uh address that we must
come together and look Beyond race and
realize America is generally because
it's in a moral and spiritual Free Fall
none of us should be defined by the
worst of what we were in the past but we
should be defined by what we want to
become in the future and that people are
motivated to change when you give them a
vision of Victories that are possible
not constantly reminding them of
injuries to be avoided what makes more
sense what that man is saying or what
you hear out of Lori Lightfoot or Pete
bootage or Joe Biden
[Music]
foreign